so this next segment is our mailbag
first i'll read the submission i'll ask
you to get a grade of it so it's either
dry moist or fully juiced fully juiced
being the most salacious and dry being
very boring and then i ask that you kind
of explain the reasoning behind it okay
so two bathroom debacles from my old job
all right first one uh one guy
from the texas but like austin texas
office
got fired because he took a dump and
forgot his handgun in the bathroom stall
whoa
[Laughter]
in the main chicago office some guy kept
taking a huge [ __ ] and then not flushing
it
like this happened for a week straight
eventually our ceo called all the men to
the bathroom stood at a table and
threatened to get the poop dna sampled
so he could identify and sue slash fire
the non-flushing culprit
oh my god
that one's fully just just because of
the
extent that the boss was prepared to go
to which i bet it's a bluff but i have
to appreciate like you got to do what
you got to do to get this monster to
stop what kind of
what kind of monster look i can tell you
right now there isn't a company in the
world that takes poop samples for dna
[Laughter]
that is
like he's not at least not casually
taking poop samples for dna certainly
not
like send your [ __ ] samples to us so we
can solve your office crime yeah because
probably to do it right they would have
to come do it not just trust some middle
manager to have collected the sample
correctly in toilet water that would
also have other people's dna in it
presumably i i think well no toilet
water should be pretty clear between
people not if it isn't flushed not if
it's not fl but that's if it should be
the only look that's a very good
question i'm not very good at dna uh
i've never had to test it i think that's
a good company uh to start somebody out
there that's listening this is your
chance to take it too much because you
know what surprisingly
we get a lot of people not sitting in
offices as gossip wow that it is yeah a
lot of people are [ __ ] and not
flushing that is really it's everyone's
everyone's favorite trademark when
they're pretty pissed off uh in the
world of gossip is to take a dump
somewhere
and neither not flush or put it in a
place or [ __ ] somewhere where they're
not supposed to [ __ ] which is
really impressive is that just some kind
of kink that the society at large won't
admit because i don't
share that kink and i don't understand
it but it does seem to be rampant the
main reason i don't even go camping
is because i'm put in a place where i'm
not allowed to [ __ ] where i want to [ __ ]
which is the toilet so it's and and and
the idea of having anyone else see what
i've created i don't want that i never
wanted that i never want that to happen
to me but like i feel like there was a
culture of i'm not that kind of artist
but i've no i've known people who send
photos uh and i really wish they
wouldn't to you yeah i had like i had a
couple friends in my past who like send
me a photo if they took something that
they considered a a hefty poop that they
were very proud of oh my god whoa you
know what this reminds me and this goes
to gossip too there was a friend of ours
when we were just out of college we'll
call them the sh
this guy's last name was schneider it
wasn't but let's just say
they
their family was notorious for having
the schneider poo knife because their
family the men in the family took such
massive dumps that for it to go down the
toilet it had to be chopped so they kept
this knife the
knife next to the toilet
oh my god
that's all i know i don't know what kind
of knife it was i don't know that's the
other circumstances
i've i've got a can with a steak knife
or like a like i now i this that's him
like i never knew that was an option
for some reason i picture one of those
like long um cake icing knives that you
get like a flat edge that's like
blunt tipped yeah
yeah
oh
wow i never it's
that's that's a impressive and b very
concerning for whatever's going on in
that family's battles
but i love that it's that it's
hereditary and
[Laughter]
it's not just one it's all of us